round seven of the US Chess  Championships here in st. Louis  while the two leader is Wesley so and  now see by kids he were busy drawing  their games two newcomers came in and  stole the show the young neophyte Maggi  Fang cruised to victory against Emily  Nguyen catapulting to Ohio native into a  tie for second place just a half a point  from the top of the leaderboard another  first-timer Yaroslav Zarafa played one  for the ages when he defeated the  reigning champion Fabiano Caruana  in dominating style placing euro in a  tie for first with just four rounds  remaining it's a race to the finish line  in the most surprising championship in  years round 8 action starts right now